[MUSIC PLAYING]
MESHACK ALLOYS: Same
is a Kenyan company.
We connect customers
and logistics providers.
What we've done
differently is figuring out
the last mile logistics,
which is a problem in most
developing countries.
I mean, we don't have
things like addresses here.
JASON ROGENA: Being
able to use technology
to solve a problem that
really nobody has been
able to solve in this region is
probably the most exciting bit.
Sendy has two Android
apps, one for the customers
and one for the drivers.
The great thing
about Sendy is you're
able to drop pins for your
pick up and drop off locations.
So it's easier for you
to identify it on a map
rather than enter in
an actual address.
MESHACK ALLOYS:
We went to Android
because the majority
of the users in Kenya,
East Africa is Android
phones, and the fact
that the process
of actually doing
that continuous
deployment to customers
is much faster than
other platforms.
JASON ROGENA: As a
startup that is constantly
trying new things, we tend
to roll out features a lot.
A cool feature in the Google
Play Developer Console
is the alpha and
beta testing groups.
We normally roll out our
new versions of the app
to groups that help us test and
get as many bugs as possible
before the app goes
into final release.
Most people love
it when the UI flow
is as easy to use as possible.
Material design offers a very
simple language for people
to understand.
And we've found that most
Kenyans appreciate it.
When developing apps
for the Kenyan market,
there are certain things
that you need to consider.
You need to make sure
that your APK size is not
too large, because
most people don't
have a lot of storage space.
You also need to check
the amount of data
that your app is
using, because people
are very sensitive of the
amount of data they use.
Battery usage is
also very important.
People don't have the luxury
of plugging in their phones
all the time.
MESHACK ALLOYS: One
of the key things
was building trust
among your users.
So one of the things
we did in the beginning
is providing free
delivery to customers.
The other way of building
trust is making sure
that we keep the customer in
the know where the driver is
through our Android app.
JASON ROGENA: The way we've
utilized the Google Play
Developer Console to
establish user trust is
at first we make sure that
our ratings on the Play Store
are high.
We also rely on statistics
such as the number
of crashes per app version.
That is very helpful
for me as a developer
to know what bugs I
should escalate and fix
as quickly as possible.
MESHACK ALLOYS: I
think integrating
local payments is very, very
key to the success of customers
using your product.
Over 90% of our customers
pay for our services
using mobile money.
We have been seeing financial
growth within the company.
We've gone from a team
of three to add 19 more,
about 23 people.
JASON ROGENA:
Being able not only
to have an impact to the end
user but also to the drivers
in our platform, so giving them
an income that they weren't
able to earn a few months
ago, is really something that
is touching for me as a person.
I feel that we are driving the
economy in the littlest way
possible.
But we're still
driving the economy,
which is enough for me.